jim-jim so we were talking last time as
maybe a couple weeks ago about how
traumatic your childhood was with your
dad yes and what you're doing with
animals now sometimes they eat yeah
animal I dogs and cats cats what let me
do the talk we have had a couple weeks
ago help you I don't yeah help me not
help me kill more problems you know I
feel like a guy outlet yeah you're
welcome here anytime
what what do you see for your future I
mean do you have any hope for things
getting better or improving or then
let's have it take one day at a time and
not count the days before they get in
yeah so do you have friends on the
street that you can trust and talk to
and things like that
I have associates you know what it's not
saying I know it's not it's kind of hard
talking to people but it takes time it
takes time talking with people is if I
made it easy for you would you want to
go over to one of these many places that
are in the neighborhood to talk to
somebody and that's inside that's all I
can do is try yeah I think I think that
might be might be therapeutic for you
I'd love to do that um do you have any
family at all not not really that I can
go to no nobody can I need this this is
your it's must double round this is
where you hang you have no place to go
for holidays really like that no you
just here yeah so ever had girlfriends
or like that no no hardly they have
relationships you know people are
different
yeah well I mean those the people down
here playing around with drugs and that
makes apartment yeah I'm doing clubs at
all yeah I know but everyone else is it
makes it hurt I don't see how could you
do drugs and living this type of
environment I I couldn't do it yeah it's
hard enough just being here yeah they
think they're gonna get hand-in-hand
sometime it's hard to get food or water
or somebody's not coming out passing out
food or food it's hard to catch me dog
did you have any remorse over doing that
no no you're just feeding yourself and
giving us an anchor maybe right yes it's
the only way I can eat some time you
know I I'm not gonna wandering and in a
store and steal nothing oh yeah
so they get kind of rough get grimy
I will look for morning metals they
gonna slip they gonna come to you
quicker than a person will if you can
talk to a six year old version of Jim
when he was a small child what would you
say to him when he was going through all
my already stuff with he's tough to
someone talk to someone who gets it out
before I get to Russia even worser than
what it is you know so what you're
actually eating them absolutely each
other tastes good
really tastes good from the seasoning on
it you know hey Mike student at the at
the risk of having a million hateful
comments on YouTube which tastes better
dog or cat well it both tastes different
it's different meat
it's different one tastes sweeter than
the other we'll leave it at that
did you have friends as a kid I was
especially so I mean I was always
throwing out the class or the class
clown never we really tried to get the
attention on my learning disability so
was kind of I kind of kind of didn't
really talk to me have you it have you
ever had a friend I asked him I had
talked to you before and they left they
they moved out of state so I don't
really have no one then you never did
you know it could kind of roughed me in
to yourself but at the end of the day if
I made it through that day it's a
blessing did you feel like you're happy
or do you just go through life just
surviving and depressed I go through
life surviving the craftsman and it's
rough sometimes man I'm telling you you
get really critical you don't
what's the I'm sorry have anyone to get
some information from work to help you
out emotionally yeah let me let me do
something for you after we're done here
maybe that might help well what was it
what was the darkest period for you what
was your childhood worse than it is now
or was there a period in the middle how
much how it was worse at least in
society you can kind of like ignore walk
away from people or it could sometimes
we get complicated too because someone
would be talking to you and you think
they talking to you but they're not
talking to you and you answer and then
they ask you what are you what the [ __ ]
talking to me for and I said you're just
talking to me so it get kind of rough
man you know you got it you got to be
able to walk away and not feel the
anxiety that you feel right at that
moment yeah so did you ever see your
therapist throughout your life yeah and
heard that was that experience like it's
like it's like crying man you know
people cry your business and I kind of
don't like Cooper crying but do you
think I'm crying like the last talk of
this one no I thought this was really
helpful man you know I I I ain't no dog
around that this week I did the mission
you know so it was pretty decent so I
didn't have to do then crazy okay would
you get the mission I ate some B's rice
some grits and some eggs some
hard-boiled eggs some fruit and salad
sounds great it was pretty good
you have any dreams of anything like
that do you ever fantasize about some
other kind of life what do you what do
you envision I was always reached what
would you do if you were rich I'll just
keep people money because yeah they
wouldn't they don't know what it is to
to have some money so I don't even know
did this happen money but I would I
wouldn't be greedy
I would spread my wealth I was like to
know how to get a job be sociable and be
able to how would you say naked in
society without anyone's help kind of
just be self-sufficient yes and being
able to do I wish I didn't have a
childhood I can't change that but I
could also change my future so if I can
try to work on that some type of way
again I love you the job you know but
he's dealing with people on the job this
is kind of harder in going to school
because they nitpick they look for
something for how would you say to
get in your position and they won't
probably one of the position before you
got there you know I don't is it's the
battle who's gonna get what yeah well
maybe there's a position you'd find that
isn't right you're not under somebody's
thumb all the time and I just don't want
to be in the nobody like I mean if he's
just sweeping the floor I know what I'm
posed to do I don't have to get confused
over if I'm doing the wrong job
or being told how to do it right so it's
it's kind of to me I mean social skills
it is that the correct work to say I
mean that's more job skills yeah I would
like to have that the social skills are
helpful as well of course you know and
be able to go places and feel happy not
not be depressed all the time you know I
think about my problems because in every
situation I know there's complications
you know some some are worse than others
some are better than others so I I kind
of I just want to be on the right track
man because you know on the right track
hey go places here it's like a just a
minimum you know because I don't know
too much I don't know the one I got try
to be to myself yeah you know I think
that's the best way to be because being
somewhere where you're not from if I
don't know something I try to ask
someone and hoping they give me the
right correct information because
without information you're stuck you
know do you have a did you graduate high
school no I didn't you didn't so you're
not really educated but but still there
are jobs you can do you seem like an
honest hard-working guys and I would
love to get mail killers just sweeping
the floor
you know you got well my channel has
enough viewers now maybe somebody'll see
this video and contact me about getting
a job for you we can we can set you up
okay give you a shot all right that'll
work that'd be great and then uh and
then we'll I'll send you somewhere down
the street that might help you work out
some of the stuff you want to talk about
or you're welcome here as well anytime
okay and I think I think with a little
help I could do better
you know instead of coming into
something that you don't know about you
know like like it's hard for me to just
go to and we don't know what to say
right now and when you don't know what
to say you kind of look stupid yeah yeah
and I I'm tired with the stupid I I need
to be able to maintain my household you
need to have a house yeah you know when
I'm sleeping on the street in the
sidewalk and with a tarp s'en and crates
blankets
strange with hey I don't have no way to
go do you feel like your social skills
are keeping you from having a job or an
employment and just the success that
you're envisioning yes if I think about
a little paid more attention to school
instead of getting sent out all the time
right now potty we have a good education
but you're able-bodied and you're you
seem intelligent you seem able to
communicate with me just fine so yeah
but that's them talking to someone and I
don't don't really know that that person
so being really dealing with
relationships I'm not good at I try to
establish what opposed to do how opposed
to do it and when time comes to it
so I don't get confused and just trying
to stay on that track is kind of hard
sometimes so I don't want to get
somewhere and it's a good job and I'm
not doing the correct thing so I want to
be able to get somewhere in life yeah I
know it's more of something better than
you have wrong yeah well I think just a
little communication on your part and
their part I think could solve whatever
issues there might be and with the right
job the right fit I think it could be it
could be something you could help you
get off the street because this right
here it's hard for me to do but you know
what isn't hard you know everything has
that title I guess how would you say
structure structure you know if I have
more structure maybe I'll deal with it
making it like yeah a little more
responsibility
yeah been living on the street I don't
know the correct words to say you know
this is a blessing that's all I can say
to be able to talk to someone
you know that ain't on the other side
judging so it's a help you know I felt
last time I was here I and I left I feel
awesome man I feel good you know being
able to talk about my problems it needs
to be hard for me to speak you know now
it's either tell a person what you mean
or what you say
it'll be direct and leave it at that
yeah you know you're a good communicator
you know there's nothing wrong with your
communication skills as I see it I think
he's blow-off it just could be your
confidence you know it your
self-confidence could be ya lacking but
I didn't detect any kind of
communication issues with you you're
soft-spoken but that's the only negative
and that's not even a negative it's just
that's your style of speaking you know
not everybody's outgoing and loud and
you know but you're you communicate very
well I know it's a way that I know yet
you can't change the past but you can
you can predict your future as I as you
were saying you know does your future
you build your future or I'm trying to
get there you know on a slow man space
you know sorry if I can do it with a
little help a man I think I could make
it in life again you don't touch drugs
you don't you know drinking not for you
just living on the street
yeah have to I mean if I if I use drugs
I'll be out of my mind and trying to
survive in the women ain't no inhale
should be able to do it down here and
not stay focused and because you got
everything Yahoo from the robber to the
thief from the thief to the to the man
is just walking across the street you
know I mean keep the way we wet it
wherever you can yeah
you know I just want to try to better
myself because I noticed a better way
you know and it just take time you know
it rome wasn't built in one day I
understand that but you know when you're
kind of hyper about getting somewhere or
how would you say you wanted it bad
enough you're motivated motivated you
know I just thank you guys man you know
for not judging me you know and uh I
don't know let's see we can do to help
you out all right Roger
thank you very much
you